everyone please welcome Pat's daughter
Maggie Sajak there's a new Sajak on the
set of wheel of fortune Pat's 25 year
old daughter Maggie who gave the family
business a try on Monday show are you
ready to touch some letters let's get
started all right
the ladies held down the fort as Pat
recovered from an emergency surgery to
correct a blocked intestine Maggie took
Vanna White's usual roll turning the
letters and Vanna acted as host here we
go
[Music]
mic brand new hairdryer yes that is
right
both gals did a fabulous job touching
letters and helping contestants solve
puzzles II we have four is but maybe the
most touching moment of all finding out
it wasn't actually Maggie's debut on the
show exactly what you say I didn't hear
that part
uh-huh uh-huh she's speaking baby you
can't quite understand it will a fortune
has been on the air for nearly four
decades et was there in 2017 to
celebrate the show's 35th anniversary
here's what Pat and Vanna told us about
the show's legacy televisions are a
fluky business and you know none of us
have predicted this you know we all
thought we'd been on to our second or
third or fourth job but would they we
just can't shake this one we're kind of
a throwback show and for some reason
people keep watching us we're very happy
they do I remember when I first started
the show I turned to Pat and said I
wonder where we'll be in ten years and
it's been 35 incredible and plans to
just keep going forever and ever
absolutely why not
[Music]